also ich bin jetzt seit 40 Jahren
passionierte Ökonom und was ich momentan
sehe habe ich noch nie gesehen ein 14
schwarze Wolken auf über Deutschland
führende Leute der der der Verbände
sagen wir werden ein
wirtschaftsschrumpfung von 20 bis 30
Prozent sehen das ist irgendwer so und
der Chef von DIHK
der BDI-Präsident sagt die Substanz
unserer Industrie ist bedroht so was
habe ich noch nicht gesehen 10%
Inflation wir haben in den letzten
Jahren sehr viel Geld gedruckt das sind
Check geschrieben worden Scheck
geschrieben worden von dieser Regierung
die uns vorgemacht hat das ist alles gut
wir können das alles irgendwie so
wegbringen mit Geld Regierung das stimmt
überhaupt nicht die Rechnung kommt jetzt
in Form dieser hohen Inflation und vor
allem ist es ein Frontalangriff auf
unseren Mittelstand die lockdowns haben
den Mittelstand schon dramatisch
dramatisch gestört und die jetzige
Sanktionspolitik unsere Regierung vor
allem unsere Duo der Grünen
Spitzenpolitiker die mehr mehr
Sanktionen immer mehr
Antipathie gegen das russische Volk auch
schüren und diesen Krieg geradezu weiter
vorantreiben wollen das schadet und sind
ungemeine Maße diese Sanktionspolitik
kein Öl mehr von Russland von kein Gas
es ist sowas von absurd das Gas wandert
dann einmal um die Erde landet bei uns
als schmutziges Fracking Gas selbst als
untergrünen Gesichtspunkt ich war früher
selbst bei den Grünen und die
Umweltgeschichte unter
Umweltgesichtspunkten ungeheuerlich was
unsere grünen Duo an der Spitze macht
das ruiniert unseren Mittelstand und
manchmal kommen wir die beiden vor wie
Auftragskiller des deutschen
Mittelstandes ja die tun alles um das zu
schädigen zum Beispiel sagt Frau bärburg
diese diese dieses Nord Stream 2 Gas
würde ausschließlich dem System Russland
System Putin dienen das ist einfach die
Frau kann nicht bis 13 ja das hilft
unsere Mittelstand die haben jetzt im
Sommer mussten die sieben bis neun Mal
so hohe Gaspreise zahlen wie die
US-Konkurrenz das Überleben die nicht
lange nach dieser lockdown-politik die
wir hinter uns als ich sehe da ein
Frontalangriff auf unsere Mittelstand
und unsere Spitzenpolitiker Habig der
mit Inkompetenz glänzt das
ungeheuerlicher mag ein guter
Kinderbuchautor
kann nichts Robert habe kann nichts
auftragskills Mittelstandes aber sie
haben eben was ganz spannendes erwähnt
sie sind selber mal grüner gewesen sind
Sie damals schon wegen der
Wirtschaftspolitik ausgestiegen oder
hatte das einen anderen Grund Achim
wesentlich war das damals Claudia Roth
und die Bombardierung von Serbien wo
Fischer mitgemacht hat und ich wollte
mich nicht parteipolitisch bilden das
war binden und konnte mit vielen
Positionen da nie mitmachen ich bin
passioniert für Umwelt ich war früher
bei Greenpeace Aktivist und Umwelt ist
mir wichtig und was unsere grünen
Politiker momentan machen unter dem
Label energieschutz Ukrainisch ist ein
vollkommen absurd wir schlagen uns mit
dieser Energiepolitik selber auf die
Nase es hilft dir Ukraine kein bisschen
es schadet Russland kein bisschen
Gazprom hat die
aber kein bisschen dass sie Sanktionen
kein bisschen Schaden das glaube ich
müssen sie revidieren es
selbstverständlich russland hat es 4%
4,2% wirtschaftsschrumpfung gehabt
selbstverständlich also es schade ich
habe es Gazprom Gasprobe so viel
gewinnen muss
Sanktion ja schon Russland ans Land ja
alle in dem Kaufhaus GUM dieses
wundervolle Kaufhaus sein Moskau da
haben sie bis vor kurzem fast nur
westliche Produkte gesehen ja ich nehme
an dass der jetzt wieder heimische
Produktion kommt dann muss man auch mal
schauen wie das die russische Wirtschaft
jetzt
ankurbelt war jetzt plötzlich nationale
Ressourcen kommen also die Sanktionen
Schaden jedenfalls uns dramatisch sie
helfen der Ukraine überhaupt nichts wir
schießen uns ins Russland geschwächt
wird wird natürlich der Ukraine geholfen
ich sage nicht dass sie uns gar nicht
schade Sanktionen aber würden sie das
etwas differenziert vielleicht auch
sehen also Russland geschwächt der
russische Rubel ist heute sehr viel
stärk alles vor der Ukraine geht der
Euro ist gerade so eine schwach eine
Weichwährung gegenüber dem Rubel hat ein
Drittel abgewertet zum Rubel die
russischen Staatsanleihen sind nicht
gestiegen im Gegensatz in Deutschland
Staatsanleihen die Währung ist stark
dass wir leiden und diesen Sanktionen
meiner Meinung nach ungleich stärker als
Russland vor allem wenn die ganzen
Gaspreiserhöhungen die
Energiepreiserhöhungen jetzt kommen
durch die Hintertür über diese
Dreiecksgeschäfte Russland verkauft sein
Gase dann doch über und das Öl über
Russland und dann machen wir den Diener
diese Heuchelei ja Abhängigkeit von
Russland und dann macht der Bärbel
Diener vor dem Scheich von Katar den
Frauen Menschen
wir Fragen hier einmal ganz kurz Herrn
brame das ist ja ein schwerer Vorwurf
wie sehen Sie das
die Amerikaner sind schlauer the
business America is business also beiden
hat ja auch Druck gemacht wollte Putin
wirklich die Stirn bieten hat aber
gemerkt dass er auch den Diener machen
muss er ist nach Riad gereist hat ein
Canossa Gang gemacht den man den er
eigentlich vor der Weltöffentlichkeit
als Paar Jahr Geißeln wollte dann
Kollegen von ihnen mit der Kettensäge
hat zerlegen lassen viel Blut an den
Händen hat Frauen und Kinder in nehmen
also den Mann hat er beknete mehr oder
weniger nicht drei Tage wie seinerzeit
Heinrich vor dem Papst aber der künftige
Hüter der heiligen Städten in Mekka und
Medina hatte ich das angesehen schöner
fisspump und wie die Washington Post
sagte bei dir kashoggi damals noch
geschrieben hat hat ihm den Stinkefinger
gezeigt also Mohammed bin Salman hat
nicht mehr Öl gefördert sondern hat
jetzt die OPEC Plus und damit auch
Russland dazu
2 Millionen Fässer pro Tag vom Markt zu
nehmen also die Preise in den USA sind
gestiegen die Inflation ist gestiegen
und damit hat eben Bayerns kurzsichtige
Handlung nicht zum Regime changing
Moskau geführt sondern zu einem
Machtwechsel in Washington er hätte
diese Wahlen dank des abtreibungsurteil
sehr gut gewinnen können aber durch
seine kurzsichtige Politik hat er das
Wirtschaftsthema Inflation nach oben
geschoben und hat damit den
Republikanern geholfen diese
Abgeordnetenhaus vielleicht sogar den
Senat zu gewinnen damit dieser
handlungsunfähig also Trump ist im
Business und Mohammed in sah man liebt
Leute wie Trump genauso wie Putin und
wenn Trump wieder da ist dann werden die
Leute sehr viel netter behandeln wenn
die westliche Führungsmacht dann wieder
mit Autokraten schmust dann wird unsere
feministische Außenpolitik sich auch ein
bisschen
Außenpolitik das ist ja ein Stichwort wo
man direkt an Annalena baerbock denkt
was halten Sie denn von Anna-Lena
Werbung als auß öfteren ja sie machen
eine gute Figur aber nicht alles ist
durchdacht und ich muss den Schutz
nehmen auch erfahrene Männer wie beiden
der ihm sagt oh mein Gott ist man must
go wunderbare Rede Polen gehalten
Warschau aber zum Schluss rutscht ihm
wieder was raus geht er wieder ab vom
Skript und viele meinen jetzt macht der
regime change die New York Times hat ihn
gefragt was willst du denn eigentlich da
in dem Krieg regime change Russland
Schwächen sowie dein
Verteidigungsminister
Schwanz nicht mit dem Hund wackelt wir
sind massiv abhängig von den USA und wir
haben kein Militär wenn ich sie daran
erinnern darf ich habe vor 30 Jahren
gedient und bei uns ist es wir halten
die Stellung bis richtiges Militär kommt
und seitdem haben wir die Bundeswehr
kaputt gespart und jetzt tun wir so als
ob wir kriegsentscheiden sind also grün
machen eigentlich ein ganz guten Job das
ist irrelevant für den Lauf die
Geschichte was wir jetzt da sagen das
was diesen Konflikt entscheidet ist das
was Amerika macht und nicht sehen
Amerika abseitsbewegungen bereits unter
beiden da ist schon durchgestochen
worden ja jetzt kommt mal zu porte wir
haben wichtigeres in Asien Stichwort
Taiwan und wenn jetzt die Republikaner
des Abgeordnetenhaus in der Hand haben
da wird der künftige Speaker Kevin
mccarth das Einlösen was er schon gesagt
hat keine Blanco Schecks mehr für die
Ukraine also unsere Kernkompetenz ist
nicht Militär wir haben kein Militär
unsere Kernkompetenz ist Trümmer Männer
und Trümmerfrauen wir dürfen dann
Wiederaufbau finanzieren und da sind wir
dann einmal volkswirtschaftlich noch
mehr interpretuier in der Zwischenzeit
wandert die Industrie nach Amerika ab
weil es da günstigeres Gas und Öl gibt
und wir merken auch nicht und das wird
dann schon ein Statement nachher sein
das Bein sehr knallhart
damit unsere Wirtschaft
wie fühlen sie sich denn als Bürger
fühlen Sie sich gut regiert von den
Grünen nehmen Sie das wahr vielleicht
haben die Grünen auch einfach nur ein
Kommunikationsproblem aktuell das kann
natürlich auch ein Grund sein
das ist für mich eine schwierige Frage
ich bin bin ja sie fragen mich als
Bürger ja gut so und ich als
Wissenschaftler aber ich versuche dann
doch auch immer wieder so wie ich
Medizin sehe und wie ich auch in den
letzten Jahren mich sehr beschäftigt
habe mit diesen ganzen Themen eine
gewisse Metaebene einzunehmen und und
die Metaebene ist Geld scheint wieder
mal ganz deutlich die Welt zu regieren
und zwar offensichtlich wichtiger zu
sein als der Mensch den Eindruck habe
ich ganz stark und das gibt Amerika vor
das gibt die die Grundhaltung die
kulturelle Grundhaltung vor ich bin
äußerst kritisch und und sehr sehr
skeptisch was da eigentlich mit Ukraine
und Russland los ist ich würde da gerne
auch eine gerne eine Ebene drüber gehen
und mir die Frage stellen was haben die
Amerikaner da wirklich vor um was geht
es hier und ich bin einfach Höch
skeptisch und und es ich sehe wie gesagt
diese Geschichten in der Medizin
ein einziges letztes Wort zu dem zu
dieser corona-geschichte es wird wieder
Geld verdient und wenn wir nicht jetzt
an den Menschen rangehen und wenn wir
jetzt nicht endlich aufhören das Geld
den Menschen überzustellen dann werden
wir wieder in Testungen enden wir werden
wieder die biochemischen Marker suchen
nach für long kovid und werden vergessen
dass es um Menschen geht die wir jetzt
in die Arme nehmen müssen mit denen wir
Beziehung haben müssen und wo wir nicht
anfangen wieder irgendwelche Cortison zu
spritzen und die Information runter zu
regulieren und wieder nur auf den Körper
abzuzielen und das macht Geld nebenbei
also die Medizin ist schon wieder dran
eine neue Cash Cow zu produzieren und
deswegen wenn ich das höre Amerika
Ukraine Russland ich denke mir die ganze
Zeit Mensch hört doch endlich einmal auf
und kommt zum Menschen zurück ich kann
es nur als Mediziner Psychologen
Psychotherapeut Argument